bonjour riadh sidaoui merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur rtl france alors on
l'a vu dans le sujet à l'instant les
journaux députés des deux pays un parle
de véritable rupture est ce que ce terme
de rupture est justifiée dans ce cas
précis
oui je pense vite d'ailleurs les
relations entre le maroc et l'algérie
sont tendues depuis
1963 avec la guerre des sables à laver
de la défense de l'indépendance de
l'algérie en 1962 des troupes marocaines
qui sont entrés dans le sahara et il ya
eu la guerre 10 163 depuis la guerre de
gaza engel à 276 donc les relations sont
tendues il ya une ouverture avec hassen
de celle des mythiques et les frontières
sont ouvertes mais en
1994 après l'attentât de marrakech les
services secrets marocains ont accusé
les services secrets algériens d'être
derrière les attentats et puis ils ont
imposé le visa aux ressortissants
algériens l'algérie par les sociétés a
répondu avec par la fermeture de la
frontière de 94 jusqu'à nos jours
dernièrement aussi une accumulation sept
décès date d'abord la construction du
maroc d'une base militaire à la
frontière algérienne deuxièmement les
manoeuvres des marques avec les membres
de l'otan troisièmement évidemment la
sphère pickas husky esponde al et
quatrièmement c'est plus important à mon
avis c'est que le moule l'ambassadeur
marocain a new york incité ses
homologues à reconnaître l'indépendance
de kabylie et encourager l'indépendance
de la kabylie la séparation de la
kabylie là pour les algériens
donc c'est la rupture après la réunion
du conseil suprême de la sécurité
alors vendredi antonio guterres est
secrétaire général des nations
unis a nommé le russe alexander even
cours représentant spécial pour le
sahara occidental
quel peut être le rôle de ce nouvel
acteur dans la relation entre les deux
pays
c'est presque impossible parce que les
relations sont tendues liée à des
facteurs objectifs qui rendent cette
relation très complexe il ya le site mal
géré estime que c'est une république
révolutionnaire le maroc que c'est une
monarchie conservatrice même leur
alliance et lan chéri sam la russie
machette petit avant goût d'avoir accès
les états unis d'amérique tant pis aussi
a confié aux journalistes avant que les
russes et les américains
chacun ce qui leur sont alliés n'est pas
racine n'importe qui ne peut pas
résoudre une accumulation de problèmes
depuis 1963 jusqu'à nos jours il n'ya
pas il n'y a pas la grippe à la tabagie
qui va résoudre le problème le problème
entre l'algérie et le maroc alors vous
l'avez dit à l'instant le conflit et de
longue date entre l'algérie et le maroc
est ce que on peut imaginer des acteurs
extérieurs
pour voir jouer les médiateurs dans dans
ce conflit
il faut faire connaître les positions
l'algérie c'est un peu là pour la
rupture or le maroc is fait hisser
d'absorber le choc et essayer de renouer
avec l'algérie de marc qui fait
d'ailleurs le chef du gouvernement sa
mission
jeudi passé à
l'ambassadeur mort à new york ne
s'exprime pas au nom de l'état marque ce
sont ses propres propos l'état marocain
ne s'engage pas classé qui ne forment
depuis l'enfer une forme de de marche
arrière disposent de nombreux l'algérie
mais le ministère des affaires
étrangères algérien qui s'acquiert caire
souligne l affaire à deux membres et les
explications est ce que ne tombe à 7
heures et par la sono ou qu'elle était
par le no 2 un mot que le problème c'est
qu'il
espère dhr le projet n'a jamais répondu
à cette question n'a jamais répondu à
cette question d'où la faire nous la
rupture totale du côté algérien mais les
marocains qui sait
mais pour des raisons économiques
évidemment on a parlé dégage pas de du
il passe par une personne qui passe par
le maroc d'aujourd'hui vont plus passer
par le manque le contrat finit au mois
d'octobre donc je pense pas que les
algériens vont renouveler ce contrat
donc aussi pour des raisons totalement
économique le maroc qui s'est hissé de
nego cible de trouver une ouverture avec
l'algérie aussi rappelons le le discours
du roi mohammed 6 verres d'espoir vers
l'algérie demande la réconciliation et
l'ouverture
de pays pas seulement économique à la
vie de marc schillaci
merci à beaucourt et ada sidaoui d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur arte france
rappelle que vous êtes expert du monde
arabe et directeur du centre arabe de
recherche et d'analysé politique et
sociale merci beaucoup